on va exploiter le gaz on va tuer la
pêche à Saint-Louis
[Musique]
la cohabitation n'est pas possible
naturel qui est là-bas
la plateforme pour qu'elle soit bien
assise mais ce rocher là c'est l'habitat
des poissons beaucoup d'espèces de
croissance il y a plus de 3000 les
petites que vous voyez qui vivaient
essentiellement de cette zone
[Musique]
il est légitime et juste
équitable que l'Afrique
continent le plus en retard sur le
processus
d'industrialisation
continuant le moins pollueur
il est donc jusque l'Afrique exploite
ses ressources disponibles pour disposer
d'une énergie de base
afin d'améliorer la compétitivité de son
économie et réaliser l'accès universel à
l'électricité
[Musique]